vejam só nossa estrela gilson oi o oi
vai jogar
[Música]
ai meu deus meus credores do sind muito
o lado pessoal do que falar andar que
seja muito menos mais um meia e os
tracks e que olha só concentrado tem
mostrado de que mais um episódio da
nossa série imprimir qualquer coisa na
impressora 3d e o que é que nós vamos
imprimir os pessoal que nós hoje nós
vamos imprimir uma estrela ninja é como
aquelas estrelas lado naruto aquelas que
nos mandam senhor muito estranha essa
estrela é considerada uma das armas mais
mortíferas né porque essa arma por
tensões num dia de vocês já sabem que
ninja mata tudo mg mata sem ninguém
saber por que os vela das sombras sabem
não é bem assim matar perceber o que é
que eu vou fazer com essa estrela ninja
ela acha essas estrelas ninja é porque o
privaria o júri quentin manter os
modelos de tem essa coisa têm sido os
maiores têm os mais pequenos têm uns com
mais lâmina suns que rodam mais outros
que vão com mais força tem muita
variedade portanto escolhi 5 e vai
imprimir 5 sobre canos e agora é só
mandar imprimir mas mas mas antes disso
pessoal o tempo para que o café porque o
conjunto é muito sério ó estava aqui há
dois dias como é que o bispo espírito
muito laquê neste vídeo e achei muito
laquê neste vídeo hoje eu vou imprimir
extremos ninja e amanhã possa imprimir
por não sair uma catana saiu não sei se
resulta portanto achei muito mais
quiserem ver também que já saíram
pessoas vocês forem novos aqui no canal
e levamos com toda roxa é e já sabem que
a regra é a seguinte a mãe para ir em
todas as notificações de estarem sempre
a par dos novos vídeos que o posto o que
é gostar um minuto para vocês fazerem
isso é deixar mentir roubar bola ao solo
que já tenha primeira estrela - já parei
só vejam só que bonita que ela é muito
linda está aqui vai ser um pouco pequena
mas eu vou imprimir em vários tamanhos e
vejam só como é bem grossa e pontiagudo
é muito fiada aqui eu acho que vocês já
repararam que eu tenho aqui um alvo em
cima da cama e sim é que eu vou testar o
júri que inclusive eu comprei que estas
quatro espera ouvir ou isopor com
desenho no brasil vôlei são duas placas
bem forte e vou colocar aquilo ao aqui
nessas placas eu não sei que vai
mas eu tenho quase certeza costura que
eles vão funcionar e vou citar aqui
nessas placas mil eu quero muito isso ok
eu preciso ligar a impressora tem um
botão aqui atrás eu não sei onde é que
está o botão hotel terá agora foi a é e
não tudo de novo como este impulso gosta
de provar o que o da arc negócio é pra
lá e agora só quer jogar não está em 3
de junho vai só vai começar agora
imprimir ainda não percebi nada porque
ela ainda está a aquecer e eu sou um
engenheiro da impressora 3d e não está
muito fácil não só os preços cerca de
maior até de procurar crescer a
temperatura que ser bom e você só
consegue imprimir olha aí já começaram a
fazer as primeiras linhas e esse é o
tamanho do nosso estilo de quem olha só
eu tenho cinco pontos eu acho eu acho
que está um pouco pequeno portanto eu
tenho que primeiro mesmo mais freqüentes
em muito maior porque eu quero mesmo é
que os grandalhões e é isso agora seus
produtos
[Música]
só tá quase quase a quase pronto o que
vou ter que esperar mais uns 30 segundos
e jorge solla que uma opção vamos fazer
o nosso time que é porque aí eu vou
tentar arrancar ao cm queimar para
detectar muito que vai lançar soluções
preciso um chute quem é serio lei é que
uma impressão da nossa estrela onde
vamos ver como é que está em 321 olha
isso está muito real também precisa
trilogia original só tá pronto vejam só
nossa estrela mim e meu tá muito por
fazer agora é só puxar os pontos e isso
vai ficar muito rico mas mesmo assim mas
que não me engano é muito esperto ele é
também aí como assim
só vou estar com um balão falar só de
estar aqui com o bolão em 321 bairro foi
a segunda tentativa press
eu acho que o pessoal agora é parte mais
chata que em primeiro os restantes
quatro anos eu já tenho aqui um e vão
ser 5 e estou muito ansioso pra ver com
os maiores porque os mais poderosos e
grossos muito grande e pouco de nené não
parece não mostrar em vídeo porque eles
vão vir muito tempo primeiro tempo cerca
de 45 horas
então quando estiverem todos impressos e
wall e não só depois de quatro horas
jatene que todas as estrelas ninja que o
imprimir mas não só é muito estrela esta
é a primeira estrela que o imprimiu
rubens impusesse uma estrela que ela
mais comum todos os ninjas que ela mais
poderosa que eu acho que é essa aqui
olha aí está que é muito comum nos
níveis de uso muita estrela e meu eu
sinto mesmo peso é terceira estrela e é
que eu mais gosto é esta aqui pessoal só
é muito grande e tem se um espiral muito
ponte aguda ou lésbicas se deve segundo
tempo meu esse foi o balão muito rápido
quatro estrelas ninja e também é muito
boa essa aqui bem grande em porto seguro
ba também a quinta estrela ninja esta
aqui ó está aqui também é bonito mas
parece que não funciona muito fácil se
repararem e [ __ ] não é assim tão afiada
então acho que esta não vai funcionar eu
acho que experimentar com
não é só está aqui aiko otta rio é muito
bom essa estrela meu sonho agora vou
tentar encher dois longe vou tirar dois
shurikens só quero fazer deste muito
livre porque se eu conseguir essa
manobra foi graças a vocês um aqui outro
que injusta a decisão de maggi eu acho
que isso aí eu acho que tem que ser
assim 32
só vamos passar então agora o verdadeiro
teste com as nossas estrelas ninja e eu
já tenho o nosso alvo é que vão para
fora
mas primeiro preciso montar olha só em
salvador até agora só precisa declarar
quem esta placa vai ser bem fácil méxico
o verdadeiro teste mesmo e tentar
construir um corpo humano e ver o que
poderia acontecer a um corpo humano se
eu fosse atingido como estrelas ninja eu
vou fazer o corpo com esta placa aqui é
cabeça com esta bola de isopor ter
ouvido isso aí falei olha aí a estrutura
do corpo vai ser um desfalque o papa
[Música]
agora foi pessoal mas um só
esta é o nosso alvo não é só tenho pena
que não deixa as condições nem mas isso
eu posso inventar não chega mas é uma
opção o maior rival 80 o usual 50 preto
ou bege e branco a 0 vamos repassar o
corpo mas agora vou ter que desenhar a
cara deu uma menina né a velha dela
floribella floribella e não só vai tomar
o carro atrás que desenhar o corpo dela
[Música]
é a bola e chutou em cima do ouro fifa
cada um sabia
já está tudo pronto agora vamos lá por
fora e testar as nossas estrelas ninja
para a irmã que só temos aqui fora já
coloquei o vão em cima do carro e agora
vamos testar as nossas estrelas ninja
que é mais pequeno eu acho que esta aqui
essa estrela
ok vou começar por esta sair daqui
preciso mandar com muita força porque
ela não tem tanto peso e vai lá pessoal
à en321 vai ou 80 pontos 80 pontes mano
caraças entrou muito lino entrou muito
para cair
vou experimentar agora é a segunda mais
pequena que esta aqui 321 vai clown
espírito fora estou fora mas pintou a
lei ea ok vou tentar outra vez só com
esta não vai
como eu disse não dispor e que irão
ainda não voltou até agora só vou
experimentar a estrela mais como uma
estrela dos ninjas 321 vai olhar estas
momento muito essa este é mais eficiente
eu acho mas se não fosse isso desponta é
esse o projeto pro 3 2 1 com duas pontas
bem de lona é gostoso com duas pontas
olha isso tem lucro 21 vai escolher qual
é muito poderosa mesmo aspecto isso não
vai mesmo assim foi só responde eu não
quero andar só são ponte de longe é
muito impossível só com esta pessoal só
com este é que vai
olha é isso olha o furacão que abriu
essa não acho que uma pessoa não consiga
atingir o seio daquela faz muito barulho
mas essa era a intenção ela faz muito
barulho e após fazer só os que sua
estrela eu acho que é melhor estilo
ninja temos aqui
esta é a receita mais simples como esta
mostram ninja eu agora vou testá lo como
floribella que está aqui olha só a nossa
amiga floribella onde é que você sabe eu
morrer na mão na mão na volta na mão aí
foi um buraco no joelho joelho foi não
num bingo bingo me ó nariz humano como
ele sair agora que vai ser agora que vai
ser aí me chamou de um pouco assim mas
aquele nariz no olho agora no olho nu
não vai atingir 1 milhão e agora ainda
vou calar a boca
agora ela é uma [ __ ] olhe agora a dinho
olhou buracão cabril sério só vocês
viram que é bem perigoso portanto nunca
brinquei construímos ninguém em casa
ok banco só vai ficar porque com esse
texto desde sempre a melhor estrelas
ninja foi está aqui
apesar de já estar partida é muito boa
porque é porque eu conseguisse estar em
todo lugar que eu quis com essa estrela
ou seja com teria muito boa e ela espera
sempre porque ela roda muito esperto
soube muito boa a 0 e agora nós vamos
guardar a nossa floribella porque ela
vai ficar para sempre no meu coração que
ela ainda está viva
só espero que vocês tenham gostado de
saber se vocês disserem muito lhe que
neste vídeo eu vou tentar imprimir uma
catana e fazer um teste por sidney isso
vocês não são inscritos aqui no canal já
sabem inscrevam se ative o cine
prosperem todos os vídeos e esse pessoal
fica amanhã até a próxima
[Música]